welcome guys little life and Brad oh hey
giving you any money last we checked in
brian was going through a rough time his
father has turned against him things
just weren't going so great he was
having trouble answering basic
criticisms because he was promising a
bunch of transparency after saying that
he was transparency was never his aim
dummy
but he started promising transparency
said I'm gonna do weekly updates at uh a
bench I decided let's just move on but
today I want to check back in because
things have changed and today actually
he announced things are big-time
changing so we got to talk about it
we're gonna hit we're gonna cover all of
it let's just sort of start off where we
ended last time with Brian basically
promising that you know he's he's
turning over a new leaf he's gonna be
transparent now and I'll be back next
week for another update on the digital
freedom platform and I'll be back next
week for another update and I'll be back
next week
where are the updates Brian where are
the weekly updates that you you know
when you were in hot water it's okay
guys let me be transparent with you I'll
tell you everything I'll give you those
third party audits that you've been
asking for where are those where is the
independent digital freedom platform now
he'll say we'll just go to freedom
platform TV just got it just go to
freedom platform TV but when you look at
it it's a sub-domain of Brian's
wordpress website so it's not
independent it's still not independent
he's just bothered to make it a sub
domain which means it's just a part of
London real it's the freedom platform
that you learn that real TV so it's
still not independent there's so many
unanswered questions where's the lawsuit
that was promised where is this
blockchain technology that was promised
and of course he'll say oh well it's
coming it's coming it's coming but don't
you think that your your followers who
are raising another sixty thousand
dollars for you just this month deserve
to know where that money's going
apparently not and it reminded me of
something that he said the first time
that he released a donations update and
I thought that is very interesting going
back through this finding this
again my plan is to be as transparent
with you as possible with these
broadcasts weekly if they're necessary
going forward did you catch that if
they're necessary going forward if
they're necessary going forward let me
translate that for you if I'm still
getting criticism going forward right
because the second we stop criticizing
all of a sudden where the donation
updates so I'm doing this for you
those of you who donated hopefully maybe
this will get an answer once again out
of Brian for where's the money
where's the motive wrong and look guys I
don't want you to think this is just me
criticizing him I don't want I'm not
leading any kind of a witch-hunt I'm not
doing anything like that I'm not
bullying anybody to be clear his old
followers are the real menaces in his
comment section I mean I think my
criticism has been pretty tame compared
to some of you guys were just roasting
him in the comments section
I want to read a few of those for you
guys but David Barclay Brian where do I
send you all my money just now here's
Ione's
Lenny reel we're all for freedom of
speech next day plenty real removed your
comment from the comment section mr.
messy where's the money gone Brian it's
every one of his videos you can go check
out any of his videos they're all like
this not sure about this he's losing
fans and I don't understand why he's
changing like this answer the people
Brian where is the app where's the
digital freedom platform you've allowed
your supporters to have questions go
unanswered that's why people are angry
with you this isn't why I subscribed
this channel is going nuts then
far-fetched Brian you are a massive liar
and the situation will turn against you
soon so this is just on his comment
section I would never tell anybody to
harass him or anything like that I've
never encouraged harassment against
Brian Rose these are people who well
they probably didn't donate but these
are people who've watched Brian Rose a
long time and they've turned on him
because he's ultimately not answering
criticisms and what's funny to me is
he's sort of oscillated from saying I'm
gonna be transparent well a person who's
saying I'm not gonna be transparent but
then he was like yeah I'm gonna be
transparent and then now he's saying oh
I don't have to be transparent anymore
cuz haters get hate here's a video
called I know you feel criticized where
basically he says he's being criticized
and he
trying to just ignore it and the
criticisms of others from someone on the
internet you never met before that is
constantly criticizing you on something
to do and you know I'm talking about me
are you Brian I won't lie I've been
through a ton of this in the past ten
weeks I mean I won't lie
this is totally mean when I take a
million dollars plus of my subscribers
money but then here's what I hate he
pretends like the criticism is because
he took a stand on free speech because
of the stands that we've made based on
freedom of speech based on decisions I
made to create the digital freedom
platform okay right nobody's mad at you
because you took a stand on free speech
people are wondering where's the money
gone then I always say this criticism is
a sign of success this is such a trap
for people who are being criticized
sometimes this is true that like you get
to a certain level of success and just
like Fame you're gonna have haters I get
that but I want to say that I don't
think that's what's going on here
because yes sometimes that's the case
but sometimes people are criticizing you
for very good reasons and if you're
constantly just saying well hey they're
just haters I don't have to listen to my
haters sometimes you do have to listen
to your haters Brian and you can't chalk
that up to success that's not success
you know right that kind of criticism
does it come from success that kind of
criticism comes from people thinking
you're miss handling their donor funds
it's just so obvious I think to everyone
maybe but I am that this is just a
problem of his own making here and he
could just as easily solve it by going
about and doing the right thing
but instead what does he do right what
does he do with all this time and now
all this money he had right well
[Music]
Hiep he break-dances and posts it and
it's just sad oh it's so sad but all of
this guys is not why I chose to to break
my silence today okay today something
happened that really made me think okay
I got to talk about this cuz Brian looks
like he's trying to move on from this
freedom platform Fiasco without
answering the questions without entering
the criticisms and changing his angle
honestly I think a lot of it's because a
lot of the traffic that he was having is
dried up if you look at his a
subscribership it's gone from spiking
when he was doing the whole like I'm
being since her deal look look at that
big spike and then now it's gone back
down after the David Icke hype after he
sucked everything out of David Icke now
he's back to his normal levels and
people aren't that excited now people
are mad but the Lennon real thing
so he'd find himself in this he's back
against the corner people aren't buying
the freedom thing anymore you can only
have David Icke on so many times before
people are like okay you said what he
needs to say and then at that point what
do you do well Brian instead of
answering the criticisms I guess his
plan is to start a reality show alright
yes you heard it correctly London real
is doing a reality show this is so
bizarre and all that can make me think
as he thought what's something that I
could do to distract everyone from
what's happened and maybe everyone will
forget about it
I know let me start a reality show the
pitch is you go to London and you're
mentored by old bribe rack people all
around the world and put them in a house
here for a week and we are gonna work on
creating your transformation and I guess
he teaches you breakdancing
I don't know what he's supposed to teach
you but uh if you win you get posted on
his platform with millions of followers
and he goes to great lengths to tell you
how famous you'll be are you ready to be
famous get used to being stopped in the
streets and having bus drivers honk at
you and all the crazy stuff that happens
to me I don't know are you guys excited
about this I for one I'll be watching it
maybe I shouldn't maybe I should just
ignore it but I will be watching this
but at the same time this doesn't get
you close to answering any of the
criticisms I don't know I don't think
people are forget but I just wanted to
make this quick video to say that yeah
Lenny real is taking a real weird turn
you know and I think he's just trying to
maybe hide from the criticisms I don't
know what's going on but it seems like
he's trying to move in this new
direction of I'm a reality show now the
views are dropping the the freedom of
speech grift isn't happening anymore so
he's just moving on strange strange
things going on and you know it's just a
day in the life of Brian with that said
you guys I think this is going to be my
last video before I go on vacation so
thank you guys for the support and I'll
see you guys next time and don't forget
to smash like and subscribe thank you
all right take one
but you didn't donate I can tell you
didn't donate YouTube shut us down we
need to feed of the phone so I need your
money
I need a love your money to pull out
your wallet
poor old uncle bribry who let you all
live for a water ride ride
they might say I'm crazy but I say but
they didn't donate
but they didn't donate let me guess you
didn't donate
[Music]